you know you're pretty famous for doing
your own thing in the sense of bands i'm
thinking about when you were with
buffalo springfield what was the big
show you didn't want to play i'm trying
to think was it um
you said to the guys i don't want to do
monterey pop that takes some balls to
tell a bunch of guys who are musicians
all trying to get their music out there
to tell you the truth i never even
really thought much about
anything other than the people that we
were writing our songs for and the
crowds that we played for live
when we went that would come to see
buffalo springfield not a hundred bands
buffalo springfield we had our own thing
so i'm saying we don't need to dilute it
with all of that and become part of that
whole thing i just just
thought that it would be good if we
stayed focused on our message and what
our songs were about and and sang our
songs directly to our fans who loved us
because of what we did so i guess maybe
i was so focused on that
anyway that's why i didn't like doing
all those big shows with a lot of people
in them i even think about crosby stills
nash and young you said goodbye to those
guys that took some nerve but i feel
like you had so much faith in your own
songwriting that no one could really
scare you or intimidate you do i have
that right that's where i wanted to go
howard i wanted to i wanted to do this
thing that was focused on what the songs
were about and the look on the people's
faces the people who came to see us and
how we connected with them to me that
was the holy grail that was that was it
that's all that mattered to me
and once we started drifting away from
that i was gone i i just and i didn't
think about it from the standpoint
anybody else i just thought if i'm gonna
be me i'm gonna be me if this is who i
am i can't do what i do if i don't act
like i believe do you think
breaking up with a band is the same way
as breaking up a marriage first of all i
didn't break up with music
right
and was i didn't break up with love
those are the two things that you would
break up with if you were dissolving a
family or if you're quitting a band
so i go back to the source
i didn't give up on the love i didn't
give up on the music
i just wanted it to be nurtured i wanted
to take care of it
if the love was suffering because the
situation wasn't right i wanted to take
the love somewhere else where it would
do better you were like one of the first
guys to get into rock and roll hall of
fame for buffalo springfield i think it
was for buffalo springfield you've been
also put in as neil young a solo artist
but why when crosby stills in nash and
young
why was it that you were not put into
the rock and roll hall of fame for being
in that band i i don't understand the
politics of that is there some comment
on that that you could clarify that
whole situation for me
i don't understand it either but it's
it's okay crosby spills in nash they
made a big they're the they're the core
of crosby stills nash and young i was
just kind of like a floating satellite
but
they're the things that made their their
vocal sound made it happen those guys
are all great songwriters they're great
singers they're great players they're
really good you know what can i say what
i'd like to know is
where the hell is crazy horse
why is crazy horse not on rock and roll
that's rock and roll